well let's talk to the health secretary
matt hancock joins us now good to see
you this morning
look how concerned are you that this is
going to cause
some sort of drop off in vaccine uptake
well there's no need for that we have
seen this incredible level of
uptake of the vaccine in this country
and what we've learned in the last
24 hours is the the rollout of the
vaccine is
working we've seen that the safety
system is working because
the regulators can spot even this
extremely rare event
four in a million and take necessary
action to ensure that the rollout is as
safe as it possibly can be
and we're seeing that the vaccine is
working
it's breaking the link between cases and
deaths
the number of people dying from covid
halved again just in the last
nine days since i last spoke to you
and is down 98 from the peak
so we we can have confidence people can
take confidence
that we have a system that we are
extremely careful
on the safety front but that the rollout
is
progressing at pace so when when you get
the call get the jab
do you think the mhra the regulator was
was
was right to raise this concern in the
way it has i mean
ian duncan smith has said you know this
is a gift to the anti-vaxxers they're
just going to turn around and say
we told you so
well thankfully in this country we've
seen this amazing level of take up far
hard night would have
possibly expected you know if you'd
asked me three months ago
uh if we get to this level of take-up i
i
couldn't have believed it frankly it's
over 90 percent
in all over 60s groups and in the
clinically extremely vulnerable over 99
percent of people have been coming
forward for their second job 99.4 that's
an
incredible rate and i think people can
be reassured that we have
the high class safety system
run by our world-class regulator if you
like
the mhra and then we're totally
transparent
with all of the side effects no matter
how
extremely rare they are like these ones
and it means that independent
people like i just heard you had the
head of the british medical association
um he's totally independent of
government but as a doctor
as a gp he can look at the data that we
published and he's come to his own
conclusion and his conclusion is that
you should get the jab because this is
our way out of the pandemic
but but it does raise questions about
the amount of concern
it does cause and of course that's
that's inevitable i mean
when you pause distributing a certain
vaccine to the under 30s that is going
to cause concern
and yet as you said yeah the risk here
seems to be
four people out of every million while
the contraceptive pill
carries a risk of five people developing
blood clots in every
ten thousand so if people find it
acceptable
to take the contraceptive pill they're
not worrying about that potential side
effect particularly
is it right to have raised to the public
awareness this very very small concern
about the astrazeneca vaccine
well it's absolutely right that we are
completely transparent
and that we have this highly sensitive
safety system that can spot even these
extremely rare events
and i i it is important though that we
we are clear about the policy so i just
want to uh
set it out because it's slightly
different to what you said in the
question there
um people these the all three vaccines
that are in use in the uk
are safe and they're safe at all ages
but there is a preference for the under
30s and so we'll
for under 30s if they want to have the
pfizer or modern jab
instead then they can um
but the not only the british regulator
but even the european regulator
and indeed the world health authority
yesterday
said that the oxford astrazeneca jab
is safe and we know that it's highly
highly effective
and there's one other important point
here which is that
of course the the regulator has taken
into account
the the risk the extremely rare risk
to individuals but the benefits don't
only go to an individual for getting the
job but to everybody
because getting the jab reduces your
chance of getting covered very
substantially
but it also reduces your chance of
passing it on to your loved ones
and we should all think about that and
take that into account and i think that
that
the combination of those two things is
one of the reasons why the uptake has
been
so high here in the uk as i say over
90 percent for all the all the
uh the over 50s and in fact
over 95 percent for people who are in
their uh
their their 70s and 80s and above okay
so how is this going to work then
for the under 30s as it currently stands
when they start to enter the program
which for the vast majority of them is a
little while off
yet you're saying it's so it's not being
absolutely pause but you're just
offering an alternative
i mean logistically how does that work
well there are 10.16 million
people aged 18 to 29 in the uk
1.6 million of them have already had
their first jab
anybody who's had the jab should
continue with the second jab because
there's no evidence of this effect after
a second jab and we have
enough more than enough pfizer a moderna
vaccine to cover
all of the remaining eight and a half
million
people aged between 18 and 29
if necessary now as you say it's some
time before we'll get on to
uh to that cohort cohort 12 as it's
called you know the next
step once we've made sure we've got that
offer out to
everybody in the current groups groups
one to nine the over 50s
then we'll move on to the people in
their 40s people like me
and then people in their 30s and after
that we'll come to
people age 19 to 29 and we'll make sure
that they have the
option of having the fisa or the madonna
jab if they want to
and um we have large numbers of jabs
coming on stream we have 40 million
pfizer jabs in
in production we have 17 million modern
jabs
that are coming through so as you can
see you know thankfully because we've
been working on this for
for over a year now we've got more than
enough jabs
and we are on track to hit the target
that we've set that we will ensure every
adult in the uk
is offered the jab by the end of july
in terms of having enough jabs i mean
that obviously gives us a great deal of
confidence here but what are we doing
about
sending uh some of these vaccines
elsewhere there are reports in the
sydney morning herald today that we've
already sent about three hundred
thousand
uh astrozenica vaccines to australia but
it's been sort of kept under wraps a
little bit
have we done that
well we've made sure that we can get the
jabs
that we need here and that's why we have
the fastest rollout and
obviously we work with the the companies
the three companies astrazeneca pfizer
and
moderna the three companies that we're
now using their jobs
here in the uk and
and then we've got more coming on track
and we talk to these companies
all the time about uh the best
route to making sure that we can get
these uh uh
these vaccines and obviously we're
engaged with our european partners as
well
yeah but to your to the best of your
knowledge
have we sent three hundred thousand to
australia
uh well we've produced the vast majority
um of the jabs that we're using the
astrazeneca jobs uh here
in the uk uh in in terms of what the
companies do that's a
that you know these these companies are
manufacturing for all around the world
and we source from
everywhere in the world so you know
there's a what matters
what i'm in control of what matters for
us is the uk government is making sure
that we get the supplies that we have
contracted
uh from the companies and it's something
we've discussed many times with respect
to
uh yeah so it starts with our york the
british government hasn't sent any
abroad
uh no the british government has a
contract with well with
um with with seven companies now uh but
of course including astrazeneca
for the delivery by astrazeneca to the
uk
for us to deploy through the nhs and
that's the bit that i'm responsible for
um well in terms of though you talk
about seven companies where are we with
the
the getting the novavax vaccine on board
and also the the johnson johnson which i
think is the single jab
vaccine which could prove to be very
useful
where are we in that process
well we've got three other really
promising vaccines
and then there's the cure vac which is
about having a vaccine that
we can adapt quickly for new variants if
there's a problem with new variants
you know the three others that aren't
yet approved by the regulator but are
proceeding really
well are the novovax vaccine
which is going to be made here on t side
the valniva vaccine which is going to be
made in in is being made in
in livingston in scotland you saw the
news no doubt earlier this week that
that has passed its phase
two trials so it moves on to the phase
three trials so that's
proceeding that's going well and then
there's the the yanson vaccine that is
the single shot vaccine and we have that
coming on stream in the summer
so all three of those are yet to be
approved formally by the regulator
but they are in the case of two of them
they're being used elsewhere in the
world
we are in uh we're in good shape on the
supply
of future vaccines um and uh
obviously we had the great news that we
started the rollout of the modern
vaccine yesterday
in camarvin in uh in wales so
it's you know the vaccine program is
proceeding well the speed of the vaccine
program is not affected by the decisions
yesterday
you can see and be reassured by the fact
that we're
taking an abundance of caution and we're
making sure that we're rolling this out
in the safest way possible
and i hope that people can take from the
approach that we're taking
obviously listening to the best science
in the world
that people can have confidence in
getting the jab
because we know that it's safe and we
know that it's effective
and getting this pandemic under control
here in this country which is obviously
what we all want to see because that is
the road back to normal
look just before we let you go can i
just ask you about the situation
in northern ireland i mean whatever has
sparked this and there is some concern
that it may be linked to the whole
northern ireland protocol and
frustration over the brexit situation
but but how concerned are you how
concerned is government
about what is happening there and what
now can westminster do to assist
well of course we're concerned and the
the root out of this is dialogue
and i'd encourage all sides to engage in
that dialogue
it is of course policing in northern
ireland is of course a devolved matter
and the the reasons for this
uh violence are complex i've spoken to
the northern ireland secretary
and he and the prime minister are
obviously working very closely
on this from the uk government point of
view
we would like to see all sides engaged
in that dialogue
and this be resolved as a devolved
matter by the people of northern ireland